حدود كرواتيا مع الاتحاد الاوروبي وهذا
اللقاء الذي يجمع بين رئيسه المفوضيه
الاوروبيه ارسنال لاين مع رئيس وزراء
كرواتيا للكوفيتش الذي نشاهده الان
الزعيمان سيسحبان رمزيان عمله يورو من احد
المسارف او من احد اجهزه الصراف في
كرواتيا للمره الاولى بعد اعتماد كرواتيا
اليورو عمله لها وانضمامها الى منطقه
رئيسيه لهذه الدوله منذ انضمامها للاتحاد
الاوروبي قبل نحو عقد من الزمن منتصف ليله
السبت همم
البلقان عملتها هنا لتصبح الدوله
التي تتيح اكثر من 400 مليون شخص التنقل
بدون تاشيرات بين الدول بينها وبهذا ارتفع
عددها بدخول كرواتيا الى 20,000 دوله اا
يقول خبراء لوكاله الفرنسي الاعتماد اليوم
سيسيمون في دعم اقتصاد كرواتيا في وقت
يسجل التضخم ارتفاعا في انحاء العالم على
وقع غزو روسيا لاوكرانيا ايضا تسبب
بازدياد اسعار السلع الغذائيه
والوقود وهذا يعتبر بكل تاكيد مع المهم في
تاريخ القوات في تاريخ منطقه اليورو منطقه
بين ذلك سيصب فقط في صالح دول الكبرى مثل
المانيا وفرنس همم طريقه
[موسيقى]
لكننا تمكننا من تحقيق اهدافنا بثقه كامله
بان الشنغن منطقه الشنغن ومنطقته اوروبا
ستكون مفيده
للمواطن الكرواتي وللا الاقتصاد الكرواتي
وخاصه همم انا سعيد بان رئيس المفوضيه قبل
دعوتي
اقفل ترومان
يوم الاحد في الاول من يناير
كان هذا وقت الاسره لكنها
منحتنا هذا الوقت كما هو الرئيس السلفاني
تحدث عن اهميه هذا
الحدث ما من شيء سيكون كما كان قبل هدتا
التاريخ نرى السيارات تعبر دون
تعطيل عبر كرواتيا كدوله سياحيه
لتصبح همم
مقصد وبالتالي هذا سيعني الكثير انضمامنا
الى منطقه اوروبا
هي اشاره اضافيه لكل من ياتون الى كرواتيا
وهذا يمثل
اختيار كرواتيا
كا مقصد للاجازات
ايضا ان اشكر
وزراء الداخليه
وزرع الخارجيه والماليه
وجلبنا هنا لنصبح في حاله الدم هذه
قبل سنوات لم نكن معترفا برام
الثلاثه عقود منذ تحريري
عيوني ايوه يا رب
اراضي المحتله من كرواتيا التي ااا الان
اشيد
بمحاربين كرواتيا ودون مساهمات المكانه
لنصبح
في هذه الدوله
ومنذ انضمامنا للاتحاد في 2013
وهذا ايضا عباره عن خطوه كبيره
حققت همم لنا
امكانيه الانضمام الى منطقه اوروبا
والشنكن
بين 15 دوله وهذا هو انجازه للهدف
الذي همم
وضعه دكتور جمال وهو
واحد من
همم
الانجازات هذه العمليات الان نختدمها
التسليم ايضا
فتح جسر
خطوه سياديه
من الاتحاد الاوروبي
357 مليون يورو وكذلك
مساهمه من معماريين سلوفينيا هذا همم
تجانس عظيم وهذا هو العالم الذي
عشنا فيه تحت ااه
الضغوط الناتجه عن الجائحه والازمه
العالميه
بسبب الاعتداء الروسي على اوكرانيا
بيبوس انه دانس في الوقت البوليسي العربيه
التي عملت على حمايه حدود كرواتيا والان
يمكن لكرواتيا انتو تضع كل قدراتها
150 كيلو متر مع الصربيه
جولدن
الان نحن نسعد
بهذا الانجاز
فقد الحدود